Speaker 1: . We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two David Pakman.
Here's a voicemail that I'm getting many versions
of asking about masks. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 7: Hey, David Pakman. Yeah, I just
want to tell you, I'm a big fan of your show.
Sounds ominous. And I use you as a resource for
most of my day to day habits. And I just want
to thank you for all the hard work you do. Thank
you. I recently have been intrigued by the kind of
new new Delta variant of the covid-19. Yeah.
Virus. And I was wondering, are you going to be
wearing your mask again? Because I think I am. I
think I'm going to be wearing my mask full force
again. I've been vaccinated twice by the Cizre and
I was just wondering if you or anyone else is kind
of looking forward to wearing your mask again.
Speaker 1: I can't say I'm looking forward to it,
but I'm expecting it the way the Delta
variant is spreading. And, you know,
we all want to think optimistically. But
when you look at the case trend right now,
again, it's mostly hitting unvaccinated people,
but the vaccines aren't 100 percent effective. So
even if you're vaccinated, you could still
get it, although the risk is quite low.
If you see the direction of things right now and
we know how long it takes to develop immunity,
we're in mid-July. We're not that far from the
start of flu season. I sort of think of the
start of flu season as September 1st, even though
technically it might be a little bit later, there
is every indication that there is going to be
significant additional masking in the fall. Now,
do I expect that I'll be wearing masks in small
groups of vaccinated friends? I don't I don't
expect that, no. But do I think that certainly
in indoor places, I mean, listen right now.
When I go to the grocery store, basically no
one's wearing masks anymore, and I tend to go at
times where it's not busy. I'm not wearing my mask
right now. I anticipate probably by September 15th
I will be back to wearing my mask in
grocery stores. And my my belief is
we're going to see a lot of more and
more of that now in red states. You know,
it's not going to be ubiquitous, but I think
parts of the country that took this seriously
to begin with are going to take it seriously.
Again, we've got a great bonus show for you
today. We've got a lot of great stuff on it.
Sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom. We will speak
to you momentarily on that bonus show if
you are a member. Otherwise, I'll see you.